сегодня мы поговорим о десяти типах
ужасных людей которые превратят вашу
жизнь в хаос вам обязательно нужно
разобраться и всячески избегать этих
людей посмотрите это видео до конца и я
перечислю все эти 10 типов и расскажу
почему Они ужасны я уверен многие из вас
знают эти типы людей и я здесь Америки
не открою но в то же время очень много
людей меня спрашивают С какими людьми
общаться А с какими людьми не общаться Я
Поэтому решил специально записать это
видео де типов ужасных людей которых
Лично я избегаю и стараюсь не находиться
в их обществе Итак первый тип - это
нытики нытики - это ужасный тип людей
так как смотрите Я очень много занимаюсь
экстремальными видами деятельности там
охота путешествие полёты и так далее Я
изучал статистику А почему в
экстремальных ситуациях очень много
людей умирает и вы знаете чаще всего это
было из-за того что в команде или в
группе людей были нытики нытики они
очень сильно деморализовать и убивают
вашу Веру они убивают вашу Веру в
благополучный исход А зачем вам люди
которые убивают вашу Веру в
благополучный исход поэтому избавляйтесь
всячески от нытиков и держитесь от них
подальше второй тип ужасных людей - это
завистники Я очень сильно не люблю
завистников причём смотрите в чём эффект
зависти есть тип завистников которые
смотрят на что-то что есть у другого
человека и хотят чтобы у него тоже это
было но большинство завистников хотят
чтобы у другого человека этого не было и
это очень негативный тип завистников
никогда не общайтесь с завистникам
потому что в тот момент когда вы начнёте
расти и у вас что-то будет становиться
больше чем у него то вы станете его
жертвой вот как отличить завистников как
их выявить и особенно вот эти два типа
завистников которые хотят чтобы у него
были как у других и второе которые а
хотят чтобы у других этого не было вы
знаете вот тех которые хотят чтобы у
других не было даже на бытовом уровне
каждый из вас прекрасно Это разбирается
и легко можно определить они как правило
настроены негативно по отношению к
успехам других они как правило стараются
всегда обесценить успехи других и они
очень сильно
Аа подвержены синдрому когда человек при
увеличивает свои а заслуги в достижении
успеха но когда другие люди достигают
этого такого успеха они принижает их
значение и
всё оправдывают Или объясняют везением
счастливым случаем или какими-то связями
и так далее неважно какой тип С каким
типом завистников вы столкнулись
желательно ограждать себя от них сразу
вы Спросите Хорошо я сказал насчёт
нытиков и завистников А когда кого тогда
выбирать так вот вместо нытиков всегда
Выбирайте тех кто в любых ситуациях ищет
выход кто в любых ситуациях видит
позитивный исход А в случае с завистника
всегда Выбирайте тех кто постоянно
учится у других кто заряжен на
саморазвитие и кто беспощаден к себе или
требователен к себе Вот это антиподы
завистников третий тип людей которых
надо избегать всячески - это злые люди
злые люди вообще разрушают светлую
энергию причём они разрушают любую све
светлую энергию они разрушают любое
общение они разрушают любое
взаимодействие с ними невозможно
кооперироваться Договариваться с ними
невозможно приходить к каким-то
плодотворным результатам как правило
злые люди всегда Ведут к конфликтам а к
войнам К борьбе а к агрессивному
поведению и к доброжелательно отношению
Вы можете невольно стать жертвой злого
человека причём не жертвой его злости а
то что находясь в его компании он просто
вызовет проблему на всю компанию
Представьте такую ситуацию вы сидите в
ресторане и этот злой человек начинает
язвить и говорить какие-то злые вещи про
другого моментально завязывается драка
вы вступаете за него так как вы с ним
вместе пришли вас обоих забирают в
полицию у вас проблемы причём эти
проблемы были порождены не вами это это
проблем была жде злость у того человека
я не против злости проявления злости как
вспышки определённой Да У каждого Бывает
но есть люди патологически злые и Откуда
происходит вот э патологическая злость
патологическая злость происходит от
ненависти к людям От ненависти к
человечеству вообще Поэтому если человек
ненавидит всех людей то почему вы будете
исключением и надо ли вам находиться в
кругу
человека которые вас ненавидят сразу
Спросите А кого выбирать нужно выбирать
общение с добрыми людьми вообще
нахождение само нахождение рядом с
добрыми людьми уже осветляет вашу
энергию уже придаёт какую-то яркость
краскам а в вашей жизни общение с
добрыми людьми всегда расширяет ваши
возможности и увеличивает вашу духовную
энергию рядом с такими людьми вы духовно
развиваете и становитесь лучше просто
даже общение И нахождение рядом с добрым
человеком делает вас светлее меняет ваш
взгляд на Жизнь меняет ваш взгляд на
других людей поэтому общайтесь с добрыми
людьми четвёртый тип людей которых надо
избегать и которых я лично избегаю - это
горделивый и чванливый лю Эти люди всё
время занимаются только возвышением себя
Вот смысл горделивость и чванливость в
том что он всегда себя ставит выше
других всегда в любых ситуациях и почему
вам не нужно с такими общаться Ну вам
разве нужно общаться и находиться рядом
с такими людьми которые считают вас ниже
себя которые всегда к вам относятся
знаете как к человеку второго сорта он
может быть вслух это не произносить но
вы Будьте уверены если он гор Лив и
чванливая это скрывает поэтому избегайте
таких людей А кого надо выбирать надо
общаться с людьми скромными вот смотрите
разница между горделивый и чванливый
людьми и скромными дело в том что у
горделивый и чванливый людей весь взгляд
направлен на себя он видит только себя у
него мир
ради него и соответственно вы для него
являетесь как бы как частью прислуги
которая создана чтобы улучшить Комфорт
его жизни скромные люди у них взгляд всё
внимание вовне направлено вовне они всё
время А смотрят на наружу смотрят на
других людей Когда вы общаетесь со
скромными людьми они всё время обращают
внимание на вас они внимание держат на
том как вы кушаете Как вы двигаетесь что
вы говорите и так далее То есть у них
Центр мира Не они а у них Центр мира
другие То есть центром мира является то
куда направлено их внимание Эти люди
точно Не испортят вашу жизнь а более
того Эти люди помогут вам достичь очень
многих высот они всячески стараются
помочь вам приободрить и всячески
помогает где-то услужить вам поэтому и
сами Будьте скромными И общайтесь со
скромными людьми пятый тип людей которых
я очень си сильно не люблю это циники и
критиканы это люди которые убивают Веру
они убивают Веру В человечество они
убивают Веру в лучшие качества людей они
убивают веру а во всё хорошее они
убивают Веру в будущее они
выхолаживалась
ничего красивого Ничего хорошего ничего
возвышенного а кого выбирать вы Спросите
выбирать надо романтиков Я сам очень
сильно люблю романтиков мне например
очень часто а нравится бывать на
аэродроме например потому что там очень
много парашютистов пилотов это люди
заряженные увлечённый романтики Они
болеют небом Мне нравится например
общаться с людьми которые там входят в
горы это тоже романтики вообще романтики
- это все люди которые увлечены очень
сильно чем-то увлечены и они дают пример
того как беззаветно служить своей цели
или а своему любимому занятию и они
заряжают своим позитивом они за заряжают
своим оптимизмом они заряжают своей
мотивации поэтому общайтесь с
романтиками с романтиками вы всегда
будете чувствовать интерес к этой жизни
и эта жизнь для вас будет всегда
интересной Вы можете подумать что люди
могут измениться в течение жизни даже
если видите определённые Эти черты у
своих знакомых можете закрывать на это
глаза и думать ну а вы может измениться
там что-то произойдёт и так далее я вам
рекомендую не тешить себя надеждами те
качества или вот эти 10 типов ужасных
людей о которых я буду говорить это как
правило устойчивые качества и они очень
редко меняются я в своей жизни не видел
чтобы циник превратился в романтика или
злой чтобы вдруг превратился в доброго
нытик чтобы превратился в оптимиста и
так далее как правило эти качества
связаны с темпераментом человека и они
не меняются в течение жизни поэтому
легче от них устрани чем пытаться их
исправить либо надеяться что они
исправят сами и самой частой проблемой
во взаимоотношениях с людьми является то
что вы терпите проявление этих черт или
черт а тех людей о которых я сегодня
говорю и надейтесь что Они изменятся или
надейтесь что они не поступят в в
отношении вас так как они поступают в
отношении других так вот именно эти
надежды и приводят вас к этим большим
проблемам Расскажите такие и подобные
истории в комментариях под видео это
будет интересно почитать многим людям
следующий тип людей - это негатив
Негатив - это люди которые способны
отбить охоту что-либо делать И чего-то
вообще добиваться они всё видят в
негативном свете они заранее как бы
предсказывают предрекают что всё
закончится плохо Эти люди которые
являются Гирей Гирей или тормозом для
вашего развития общение с негативно
настроенными людьми может лишить вас
энергии оптимизма и Веры поэтому
избегайте таких людей негатив всё видят
в чёрном Свете они не позволяют вам
двигаться вперёд и преодолевать
жизненные трудности с кем тогда надо
общаться вместо негатив лучше выбирать
людей позитивно настроенных жизнелюб тех
для которых жизнь интересна и
многообразна тех которые видят во всём
возможности в отличие от негатив ков
которые во всём видят только проблемы
Вот даже когда вы ставите какую-то цель
и говорите делитесь ей с кем-то из своих
друзей или знакомых Посмотрите кто Как
реагирует если один реагирует и говорит
О это нереально Вот ты не представляешь
что тебя ждёт там Какие проблемы и так
далее и так далее То это тищ если он
скажет О классно Молодец классное
направление конечно Попробуй то это как
правило тот человек который позитивно
настроен поэтому избегайте негатив ков
они никогда не позволят вам достичь
каких-либо значимых целей седьмой тип
людей о котором я хотел бы поговорить и
которых надо избегать это хитрые и
Скользкие вообще я очень не люблю хитрых
людей они крайне ненадёжный они всегда
думают лишь о своих интересах вот хитрые
иль люди Я не видел чтобы они думали о
ком-то они всегда эгоистичны И думают
только о себе Когда вы общаетесь с
хитрыми скользкими людьми рано или
поздно это закончится тем что на
каком-то повороте он всё равно обойдёт
вас и что-то у вас либо украдёт либо
сделает что-то короче воспользуются вами
опасность этих людей в том что они могут
испортить вашу репутацию и обесценить
ваши достижения поэтому избегайте хитрых
и скользких людей а с кем надо общаться
общаться надо с честными и
ответственными смотрите хитрые люди Они
всю свою хитрость и скользкой для что
это за тип поведения Почему они хитрые и
Скользкие Это тип поведения который
помогает им избегать ответственности
хитрые и Скользкие суть если брать это
те люди которые всячески хотят получать
плоды а ответственность перекладывать на
других вот суть любой хитрости и
скользкости А зачем вам такое когда
плоды получает он а ответственность на
вас поэтому общайтесь всегда с честными
и ответственными людьми с теми людьми
которые
А говорят всё как есть и которые готовы
брать ответственность за свои поступки с
такими людьми вы будете себя чувствовать
очень надёжно с такими людьми вы можете
ходить в разведку восьмой тип людей
которых надо избегать - это подлые люди
Почему их нужно избегать суть подлости
заключается в злонамеренный
Они что бы ни делали их действия всегда
злонамеренный
подлость и предательства могут привести
к серьёзным эмоциональным и финансовым
потерям разрушая ваше доверие и
межличностные связи поэтому не общайтесь
с подлыми людьми это не не вопрос даже
ситуативность это такой тип людей они
Где Вот подлость и зависть - это братья
они рядом идут вот если поставить их на
одну чашу и посмотреть что такое
завистливый человек который хочет чтобы
у вас чего-то не было А что такое подлый
человек если первый человек просто хочет
чтобы у вас чего не было то подлый
человек делает действие чтобы у вас
чего-то не было а с кем об общаться
общайтесь всегда с открытыми и
порядочными людьми с которыми надёжно
которые вас не кинут с которыми можно
делать любые дела и любые проекты
девятый тип э ужасных людей которых надо
избегать - это люди трусливые общение с
трусливы людьми может ограничить вашу
готовность к риску ограничить вашу
готовность брать на себя определённые
риски А ведь взятие на себя принятие
рисков - это ключ к профессиональному
успеху ключ к успеху в бизнесе или К
любым достижениям жизни не беря на себя
риск вы не добьётесь никаких значимых
достижений и трусливые люди всегда будут
вас оттягивать или отдёргивает сость она
всегда рядом с подлостью и трусость
всегда рядом с хитростью люди которые не
хотят брать ответственность а хитрые и
Скользкие люди - это те люди которые
избегают ответственности и подлые люди а
это те люди которые не могут напрямую
сделать Вам гадость они как правило
трусы то есть и хитрые Скользкие люди
трусы и подлые люди тоже трусы поэтому
трусость является фундаментом и для
подлости и для хитрости и скользкости
поэтому избегайте хитрых людей общайтесь
с людьми смелыми которые говорят то что
думают которые высказывают то что видят
которые не боятся ответственности могут
брать на себя ответственность и десятый
тип людей я избегаю это люди равнодушные
равнодушие окружающих к вашим целям и к
вашим стремлениям может уменьшить вашу
мотивацию к успеху более того вот
равнодушие оно на самом деле такое очень
неприятное качество человека когда
человек как бы ни рыбы ни мясо от него
Никакой пользы очень часто от него и
вреда нет но и пользы Абсолютно никакой
вы просто тратите время и энергию на
общение с таким человеком потому что он
не радуется вашему успехом Ну он и не
радуется вашим неудачам вы хотите
получить от него какой-либо совет так
как он равнодушен ему пофигу до вас то
его советы как правило либо он не даст
советы либо советы будут никчёмные
поэтому общение с равнодушными людьми -
это просто потеря вашего времени Поэтому
Выбирайте неравнодушных тех людей
которые любознательны и небезразличные к
жизни к вам к чему-либо тех кому вы сами
не Не безразличны потому что общаясь с
равнодушным человеком Вы должны понимать
что он к вам тоже равнодушен А зачем вам
общаться в этой жизни с людьми для
которых вы равнодушны или которые вам
равнодушны Поэтому всегда общайтесь с
людьми для которых вы для кого Не
безразличны и он для вас не безразличен
то есть с теми людьми которых вы любите
которых вы уважаете и в среди которых вы
хотите находиться этим выпуском я хотел
бы до вас довести а одну главную мысль
Мы в этой жизни все Хотим стать
счастливыми Это первое Второе Мы хотим
добиваться определённых целей и
становиться успешными так вот помимо
всех планов стратегий ваших целей
действий и так далее очень важно а
управлять той средой в которых вы в
которой вы находитесь когда я говорю
управлять своей средой это не то чтобы
управлять другими людьми А это значит
управлять тем с кем вы общаетесь Если
вам среда не нравится уйдите из этой
среды в другую среду которая
способствует вашим целям которая делает
вас счастливее и которая способствует
тому чтобы вы добивались своих целей и
становились успешнее поэтому Цель этого
выпуска показать вам что помимо действий
по достижению целей существуют ещё типы
людей которые вам не позволяют стать
счастливыми и успешными избегайте их